we have an idea what the Senate might do
and we're still waiting to get some
answers on the legislation but I
understand we could have a
framework Monday or Tuesday of the
biggest IM immigration reform since
Ronald Reagan was in office now if we're
going to get a secure deal and if people
are smart if they want to know what will
actually work they will go to my next
guest he is Congressman Henry quor
unfortunately for the most part
Democratic administrations have ignored
him when he sat there sincerely just
wanting to fix the problem and they
tried to primary him for trying to do
that congressman quar from what you
understand how legitimate are these
negotiations Am I Wrong to be optimistic
right
now I think you're right I think there's
a very sincere efforts to get something
done and it's got to be something that
got to get the 60 votes in the Senate
and then in the house uh the speaker has
to let the will of the house work here
look we know what happens in the house
the far left is going to say no the far
right is going to say no but I think
there's enough Republicans and Democrats
that can say are we doing the right
thing at the border and if we have the
right repercussions at the border we can
stop this historic numbers of people
coming into the United States do you
agree that this is the worst you've ever
seen oh yeah I mean if you look at the
numbers uh no doubt about it I think
last month we had over 302,000
individuals when you get 10 12,000
people uh a day coming to the Border we
have a humanitarian crisis and again you
know the president if I was advising the
president I would say hey address the
American public tell them that there is
a humanitarian crisis at the border that
you're going to get on it you're going
to come up with something to address it
it's it's not only the money part of it
but we do need to make some policy
changes I mean right now it's so easy
for people to say fear and they get in
and then they wait four five six years
before they get a hearing in front of an
immigration judge and most if you look
at the numbers for the last 25 years 87%
of the people are going to be rejected
because they don't qualify for Asylum
but it's too easy to come in at the
beginning Congressman I I don't I'm
going to put you in an odd spot now you
were sitting there basically spitting
into the wind trying to tell your party
this was a big deal and they were
ignoring you until Governor Abbot put
them on buses signed releases and say
you can go to the city you want to and
they were choosing DC uh Philadelphia in
some cases Chicago but most of all New
York it became a national no problem
these are democratic cities does
Governor Abbott deserve a uh your
respect for doing
this well look let me put it this way
actually the first city that started
doing this was actually the City of
Laredo was a Democratic mayor that was
sending people up to Dallas and Houston
and he got calls from uh the mayor in
Houston saying hey don't send them over
here so so it was a Democrat doing that
and again most people are going uh you
know they'll fly they they'll get on the
bus but yeah Abbott was able to to serve
that wave and I think he did it in in a
good way to get the attention because
now you got you know the Mayors
Democratic mayors that are saying what
we have been saying at the border for
many many many many years uh they're now
saying uh what we've been saying that
there's just too many people coming in
and it is expensive to uh you know take
care of those people once they're in the
United States when California gives
illegal immigrants healthc care and now
transition th surgery if they choose
that when when uh New York says I give
you three meals a day we'll do your
laundry uh and we'll give you housing do
they understand that that's a magnet
that it makes everything
worse you know there are push factors
and pull factors push factors are you
know the poverty the crime looking for a
job in the countries but then there are
pool factors that can be very very
powerful uh the examples you gave those
are pool factors powerful uh the fact
that they can get to the Border hit a
little speed bump be there process get
processed and then get flown uh
somewhere else that is the pull factor
and if we don't change that pull factor
at the border they're going to keep
coming not only from Mexico Guatemala
Central America South America but from
over 50 countries uh across the world so
you agree that uh by the way going to
dissolve in some New York Post photos of
basically what's been happening in New
York City even when they the buses go to
New Jersey they're hopping on trains and
going to New York I mean look at some of
this and look at what they're having
it's no life for either any of us and we
can't afford to do it we are actually
spending $6 billion on illegal
immigrants and there's so many needs in
this country but Congressman it looks
like that's going to be in the bill it
looks like they're going to change
Asylum to say saying there's fear go to
a different part of your country it's
not going to work uh Catch and Release
will be ended the wall will not be
finished that's going to aggravate a lot
of Republicans actually bothers me too
uh so that's one thing that's not going
to be in it do you believe that speaker
Johnson will lose his job if he gets
Democratic votes to pass what's handed
to him from the
Senate well I think that's something
that you probably have to ask somebody
else on the Republican caucus but I
would tell you speaker Johnson wants to
do the right thing does it King Jeff
come up with uh I'm sorry this would
would would uh would Jeff also push
Democrats to vote for
something I I think uh uh speaker or
should I say the speaker Johnson will
see what he needs to do with caucus
leader aim Jeff will look at the at the
at you know the language and uh and
hopefully if it's good uh hopefully I
hope he does that but he's got to review
it I got to review it I have a general
idea of some of the things that we're
looking at I think we do need to change
I think as sen Senator C said you know
we certainly have to address the Asylum
it's just too easy for them to claim
Asylum the initial one I think the
parole should be on a Case by case basis
not a blanket Paro uh so those are
things policy changes have to be made uh
funding we have to put funding in the
right places uh we have to put eyes more
money for eyes so they can be sent back
to the country of their origin
absolutely Congressman they'd be so
smart uh to ask you you should be in
these talks no one's put more time in to
find out answers I always appreciate
having you on thank you Congressman hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else